MARKUS KLUTE:
Welcome back to 8.20.
So this section is a preview
or maybe a review of 8.02
depending on whether or
not you have listened
to electromagnetism
[? already. ?] So first I just
want to remind you how we relate
electric and magnetic fields
and how we can describe
them from a different moving
reference [? point. ?] So if
the reference point moving in x
direction, then the x component
of the fields do not change.
But the transverse
components do change,
as we have discussed before.
The core of this
section is about how
the fields-- the electric
and magnetic fields
are actually
generated by charges
and their distributions.
And this relation is described
by Maxwell's equation.
The entirety of 8.02 are
classes on electromagnetism
is about how to understand
Maxwell's equations.
So I'll do this here in a
very short and brief manner.
So you can write
Maxwell equations
in four different equations.
The first one is
called Gauss's law.
And if you read the
equation, it just
says that the divergence
of an electric field
gives the density of
the source or the charge
density of the source.
You can also read this equation
by saying a charge density
generates an electric field.
So charges generate
electric fields.
Similarly, Gauss's
law for magnetism
can be read as magnetic charges
generate magnetic fields.
Or the diversion of
the magnetic field
is the density of
the magnetic source.
However in nature, we haven't
observed magnetic monopoles
or at least not yet.
And so therefore,
there's no such thing.
There's no magnetic density.
You can read this equation also
saying that all magnetic field
lines need to be closed.
And so that's another
way to look at this.
And we have Faraday's
law, which means
that we can induce
electric fields
in a coil equal to negative
change of the magnetic field.
In other way, if you want
to create an electric field,
you can do this with a charge.
Or you can do this by changing,
as a function of time,
the magnetic field.
Changing magnetic fields
generate electric fields.
And very similarly, we
can look at Ampere's law
and saying that changing
electric fields generate
magnetic fields.
And you can also generate
magnetic fields with a current,
as we have seen in the
previous [? section. ?]
So this is how we can
understand [INAUDIBLE] Maxwell's
equations.
The difficulty
now, 8.02, is often
to understand the concept
of fields, the fact
that there is a
[? vector ?] describing
the strengths of
this abstract thing,
of an electric or magnetic
field somewhere in space or
[INAUDIBLE] are
changing this time.
That's [? complicated. ?]
And then there is
also a little bit
of functional analysis
needed in order to understand
and how to apply the electric
field by a specific charge.
Those cases can often
be simplified by having
symmetric configurations,
like a charged atmosphere,
or a point charge,
or a cylinder,
or charges along the line.
In those cases, those
integrals or those divergences
can be calculated in a
straightforward manner.
OK, so then there's
another aspect
which is relating
[? charge/discharge ?]
distributions or
fields to forces.
And that's done
by Lorentz force.
So the force of the
charged particles
which is moving in
electromagnetic field
is given by the strength
of the charge itself
times the electric field, plus
the velocity of the charge,
plus the strength of
the magnetic field.
OK, what that means is I can--
if I put a charge in an electric
field, it's being pulled.
It's being accelerated.
If I have a moving charge
in a magnetic field,
it's being bend around or
the force bending it around.
And then I can have this
relativistic equation
of motion, which uses our
relativistic equation of motion
and sets it equal to
our Lorentz force.